welcome to this video playing at
tactical from Spain yeah let's see
what's impossible him the first game of
the session no warm-up games let's see
what happens my session before that was
very short just at four games but I won
all four so yesterday's short but sweet
session maybe maybe to be continued I
hope that a tactical I played him twice
for one out of two and he's also playing
this somewhat outdated version of the
same share with g5 okay let's see
normally you play a 3 here all the time
yeah I guess so all of them also here
yeah long term I would like to play you
for of course how to how to get this in
I'm sure yet let's make a good
multi-purpose move whenever the f porn
is missing at some point which will
happen after you for King edge one is a
very often the decent move that helps ok
he's moving the night that's good news
actually because it seems that he's not
putting any pressure on deform yeah he
can put it on c4 but i have a form this
is yeah after you for now I have reached
my strategic goal unless black has some
tactic that I'm not seeing is already
already outplayed here i geti five f4
and my dream position we are taking
Bishop g4 something something like that
some
drastic otherwise this is simply bad for
black also c4 is a very shaky piece i
mean the tonight that night is
unsupported yeah I think Bishop g4 is
the move maybe but Quincy to em Quincy
to after that the night is the
threatened twice yeah you cannot you
cannot even do that so I'm just just a 5
here or or something else Quincy three
might be might be a move maybe I can
play this first here so that Quincy 3
can be easily answered with a 5 and Roxy
one but okay if I first group c 1 first
I don't know okay
so should I play Roxy one even on now
the queen is probably worse on a three
zones and on c3 okay how do i do I win
this now Bishop age six maybe how to how
to do that that's even even the
sacrifice is very close to working on
age seven
Queen Queen h5 the still d3 hanging so
that's probably not it
mmm night h5 is also attractive cam
playing one of those moves it's hard to
tell what's best
Jay I'm not sure what you should do yeah
maybe I had bishop age six already
something something more violent
okay so Bishop h6e I am I guess no no
that is a no I just wanted to undo the
move I know I put Bishop is free in no I
just died ok well the position is so
good maybe maybe I can play this still
it's one of the few ways not not he
didn't take it that's funny i'm not sure
why but okay so i gifted timberho tempo
which is really valuable him i wanted to
go here mm-hmm believable now that's a
very valuable temple radio protecting f7
m
ok
I it's still dangerous but probably not
not an objective we know anything the
tempo is very very valuable as men as
mentioned yeah I know I get the chicken
I'm King edge a door what does this move
I don't know time warning check
twin to H form
I can take on f6 first that sets a
problem
and that's that's the problem do I have
some intermediate move here I don't
think so it's very very unfortunate rook
t3 does that [ __ ] here to see eight
would be nice
I only have five seconds yeah I made
this this mouse slip this is so this is
really a shame after Jack like was
really completely lost already that was
basically no hope for him to survive the
position but the whole tempo is too much
in such a short shots at such a sharp
situation you know the position is even
good for white still but okay we like to
talk as one was on time yeah if what
what a nonsense yeah but should be three
I was hovering here around those squares
not sure if I go with g5 and age six and
then I put it back on III how idiotic is
that you can look at this what is the
best here bishop age six is just one
point seven oh no it goes to two yeah
Queen d2 wins as well yeah the tech is
far too strong far too strong and it's
of course totally clear that black
should lose here Knight a5 is a question
mark another ? and this is just a just
totally totally lost I mean II five and
i have f quicker wins here 94 94 is also
killing him he has no defense on the
kingside absolutely no defense yeah it
does not matter they all win queener
three wins but this is well yeah Queen
d2 is also stronger yeah that's that is
actually something that is quite quite
nice because the Queen will ultimately
arrive on a dark square this is this is
probably the strongest him yeah and this
he can just take it which is the next
mysterious move but ok it's maybe not
that maybe not that clear the compass
just on minus one after the caption
okay well yeah still have an attack but
it's of course phallus far less um I'm
forcing interesting account gives gives
wide a good position with rook a one
interesting line here and then then
night to g7 yeah that's a very computer
computer like line but it it will
probably win the exchange now if he
moves the rook I have stuff like that
with Bishop g5 oops Bishop g5 coming
interesting yeah this is this is still
about equal according to the machine
check here what is good again but very
difficult Queen f2 is right I went here
okay yeah I can still fight yards is
just it's not losing yet at least
according to stock fish and gives this
is equal after Queenie one but okay i'm
down to 10 seconds the just whole
business really a bit irritated me and
why does not better at the end i forgot
about the the rookie move to d3 yeah
this is safe saves the day of course for
black yeah yeah why should definitely
win after very blacks very bad opening
play but this this weird Bishop e3 move
it it was it was costing me costing me
precious time on the board and on the
clock okay thanks for watching